in this video we're going to go back to
school and we're going to cover some of
the basic terminology of email some of
this may be very familiar to you some of
it will be new let's get started and
talk about the most basic element of
email and that's the list whenever you
hear email marketers talk they're going
to be referring to the list and simply
the list is the list of email addresses
that you have this list can be broken up
in many ways but ultimately the list is
your customers your prospects anyone who
has said they want to receive an email
from you but ultimately the list is the
group of people you are going to email
now you can grow your list by collecting
email addresses the majority of
companies collect the email address from
a transaction on the website they can
come from many other methods but just
gathering those names from your website
from people that say they want to hear
more from you or they want to receive
information is the primary way of
building that now the email server is
very much like the post office of email
it routes your email from your computer
to the intended destination and so it's
essentially the post office with the
mailman taking your email routing it
through the server to go to the person
that you are sending that email and so
it can be your business or internal
server that you have inside your company
it can be a third party service such as
a GoDaddy or Rackspace or you can be
using a third party email service such
as Constant Contact
MailChimp some of those that will take
care of your email marketing list and
will be that third party go-between for
sending out a mass amount of email to
different people and that third
party handles all of the legalities and
the sending options for that so an ESP
is an email service provider they are
the ones that can handle and maintain
your list as well as enable you to build
an email through their service and send
it to those people and the email service
provider will enable better management
of your list now one of the
methodologies of sending email that is
called a batch and blasts is taking the
same email message and sending it to
everybody on the list typically this is
done with a newsletter or a company
update and what it does is it assumes
that everyone is interested in this
message so that's why we call it the
batching blast we're taking all the
names that we have and we're sending
them the exact same email now sometimes
for best practices we tend to back off
of this approach because we've found
that targeted emails tend to work better
but batch and blast it's just sort of an
offhanded way of saying we're sending
the same newsletter or the same
communication to everybody we have on
that list now how you build your list is
very important how people have let you
know that they want to receive an email
message is critical and so an opt-in is
when someone allows you and gives you
permission to send them an email an
opt-in is one of those very critical
factors that helps establish your
company as following best practices in
email marketing and opt-out is where you
allow people to say I don't want to
receive email from you and so it
requires action on the part of the
recipient to say I no longer want to
receive email from you in a lot of laws
require opt-outs to be part of mass
mailings so that a recipient can opt out
of uture mailings at any time an opt-out
can also be called an unsubscribe where
they can go in and say
I no longer want to receive email
messages from you as a company or I just
want to unsubscribe from this list and
so giving people the ability to manage
their own email contact settings is
something that allows you to comply to
spam laws but also gives your customer
additional ability to manage their
contact preferences now I've mentioned
the word spam numerous times but chances
are you know what that is spam is
anything that you receive that's
unsolicited or unsubscribed if you've
never subscribed to receive email from a
specific vendor or a person or an
organization and it shows up in your
email box anyway that's considered spam
there are incredibly powerful spam
filters on email servers everywhere and
so you need to make sure that you are
abiding by best practices and spam laws
in order for your email not to be
considered spam in talking about spam
what differentiates different types of
messages is the understanding of what
makes a transactional email if someone
is purchasing from you if they've
requested information if they're looking
for a download that is a transaction
they have received value for giving you
their email address and that determines
moving forward if they are receiving
spam or if they have opted in to receive
email messages from you now a blacklist
is something that you do not want your
company to be on a blacklist is set
aside by email servers as a gateway to
preventing people who have repeatedly
abused email by sending spam by setting
unsolicited email to other people and so
the blacklist limits the ability of
those organizations or those mail
sources to send unsolicited email the
open rate is how many people opened your
email to view it the first measurement
that people typically look at we
comes to email marketing is the open
rate and it's also the first trap that
they can fall into they tend to view
open rates as the primary indicator of
success of an email marketing campaign
but unfortunately open rate doesn't tell
the full story and it's more of a fuzzy
number because not all email clients
report the open rate the same
it's very undependable and so really
just use the open rate as a guide rather
than focusing on it as a measure of
success a click-through is much more of
a hard measurement of how people
interacted with your email so whereas we
can look at the number of opens and get
an idea of how many people looked the
click tells us how many people took an
action to click through the email to the
landing page that we have set up for
that destination and so it's much more
of a hard number to look at success of
an email campaign now the email client
is whatever your target recipient uses
to view email it could be Outlook
it could be Mac mail it's whatever they
use in order to open the email that's
the email client now there's also it's
called free mail and that's any free
email service such as Gmail or yahoo
mail or hotmail
their web-based email accounts which act
a little bit differently than corporate
email accounts or other types of email
accounts and so that's going to come in
when we look at deliverability and how
your message appears to the recipient
you